what about this environmental stuff you
really are worried about it uh I am and
I'm not I just also feel like you know
it'd probably be a good thing if most of
us died there's no there's nothing wrong
with driving a gas guzzling car there's
just too many people doing it yeah so
you got to figure out a way to like thin
out the herd and it's too late it's not
these are the hard decisions that are
gonna have to be made we are we're here
to hear about some bad choices though
you know how I would do it what I would
I would randomly sink cruise ships why
don't you randomly sink cruise ship you
get like 2500 to 3,000 people of whack
right and I don't think I think it's a
good mix of people to get rid of for the
second time they catch on no because
this is what you do as you're sinking
them you're building an exact replica so
as you're eliminating people you're like
creating jobs and you just
moving it around right now Trump is
watching TV like hey guys that's the
stuff you said you can't think that's
what a white guy who lives at the top of
a skyscraper sounds like you know what
maybe you gotta expect them to be
talking like understanding yeah people
cuz that a full sentence I don't know
you do are you just recently you bought
a you bought a house and you're worried
about there's no rain out here did you
you know yeah yeah even this beautiful
bathroom with the steam shower and all
of that and first thing I did was I paid
the thing off to get those banker creeps
off my back that was one thing they did
like that Trump said when he was talking
they said you went bankrupt my bankrupt
like four times because I got hundreds
of deals and start making out those
bankers like they're a bunch of babies
he's like they're killers they are they
need to be eliminated they could only
get them all on a cruise so you can't
you can't do it they're too big they own
all the politicians so anyways the house
think yes yes when I put a steam shower
and now I can't use it and I don't know
I think it was a dumb idea to buy out
here it was a dumb idea to buy in Los
Angeles yeah like I think I should have
bought like on like Lake Superior or
something up there with all that fresh
water figured that'd be the last one
that dries up what do you guys you
sitting there like being quiet like what
I'm saying is insane
you